the Trump administration is about to
roll back one of President Barack
Obama's signature policies on the
environment the move comes from the head
of the Environmental Protection Agency
that's got bruit in the next half hour
Prewitt is expected to announce a
reversal of tougher Obama era standards
for rules on greenhouse gas emissions
and fuel economy that would set up a
showdown with lawmakers and
environmental groups meanwhile the White
House is reportedly reviewing reports
that Pruitt paid a below market rate to
live in a Washington condo tied to an
energy industry lobbyists chip Reid is
at the White House good morning good
morning Pruitt says rolling back
greenhouse gas emission and fuel economy
standards will help the car industry and
consumers but it's expected to ignite a
firestorm of criticism here in
Washington I think that that measuring
with precision human activity on the
climate is something very challenging to
do EPA Administrator Scott Pruitt has
previously questioned the impact of
carbon dioxide emissions on the
environment something President Trump
also doubted on the campaign trail a lot
of it's a hoax it's a hoax in a press
release the EPA announced the current
carbon dioxide emission and fuel economy
standards are not appropriate and should
be revised but did not say what those
revisions would be the move could set up
a legal fight between the Trump
administration and California which has
vowed to stick with the current
regulations and has a waiver through the
Clean Air Act to set its own emissions
standards the announcement comes as
Pruitt is facing new ethics questions
regarding a condo he rented from the
wife of a top energy lobbyist until last
July Pruitt was renting the condo for
$50 a night from the wife of Stephen
Hart chairman of a top Washington
lobbying firm hearts firm reportedly
lobbied to scale back Barack Obama era
EPA rules limiting greenhouse gas
emissions from existing power plants the
EPA also reportedly signed off on a
pipeline plan for another company linked
to the firm at the same time Pruitt was
renting the condo I was flying coach
Pruitt is also facing questions about
his first-class plane travel which costs
taxpayers tens of thousands of dollars
Pruitt said it was necessary because of
threats he's received the security
detail that I had
they want to meet on position applying
to exit expeditiously if an incident
arose the EPA says quote there is no
connection whatsoever between any
decision administrator Pruett has made
at EPA and any place he has lived and
that Pruett is focused on advancing the
President's agenda there are reports
this morning that Pruitt's job is in
jeopardy but we're told the president
called him last night and said keep
fighting we have your back
chap thanks so much chip Reid at the
White House